we have her new bachelorette a little
bit out of left field but you knew her
from winter games Claire I do think this
was a bit of a response maybe to the fan
frustration with the maturity level of
the women Claire's in her late 30s what
do you guys think of this I mean for me
I'm shocked
100% shocked this was not a name that
would it came in my top 20 list before
the announcement I I love that you know
she is mature and she does know what
she's looking for and she really wants
to find a partner you know we've been
shocked with kolten when he was a
bachelor we were shocked with Hanabi
when she was announced to the bachelor
and that turned out great for for the
franchise and so I'm shocked but I
believe this could be good Becca I'm
all-in I'm excited
I watched Claire I mean on Juan Pablos
season and then winter games I don't
know her but I'm ready to kind of go
back to the basics to you know bump up
the maturity left level a little bit and
to finally have hopefully more deep real
connections and conversations and so I'm
excited to watch her did it feel like
we're watching a season of influence or
wannabes that's a lot of people and this
is a response I think it's gonna take us
away from that you know this is a season
that I think we're gonna see a lot of
people who really desire to find
partnership in relationship because
they're at that stage of life where they
have to start asking what is the rest of
you know what does the rest of my years
look like and I love that I think it's a
great move
[Music]